let's introduce the next speaker
um it's uh daniel lee he's calling in
from new york
um it's very early there right now i
believe
uh and he is one of the original stan uh
developers uh which you may know is the
uh cbs plus library for inference and
posterior sampling
um and it's one of the non-focus uh
sponsored projects so we're very happy
to have him here
welcome daniel um
he is also right now the co-founder and
cto
of general ball which is attempting to
estimate treatment effects for cancer
patients
so um uh daniel i'll let you take the
floor
this is the outline so i'm going to talk
about why sten exists when it's useful
and why i use it
um thanks for being here
uh a quick intro to who i am um
i've been a stan developer since 2011 uh
so that's
you know since the very beginning of the
project i'd consider myself a bayesian
statistician
in the past i've been a software
engineer working on operation
operations research type of projects and
something that's kind of unique is i've
been working on something stan related
pretty much every week for the last nine
years
i'm also a co-founder of generable and
we as mentioned we estimate
efficacy of oncology treatments for
early phase data um the interesting
thing here is
that we actually use stan for our
analysis
um i'll start with why stan exists
and i'll start with the motivating
problem um this was from 2009 i used to
work with andrew gilman
and uh from 2009 to 2017
and the the the problem here is that we
want to estimate public opinion from
polling data
so what polling data is is you'd get a
sample of people and oftentimes the
polls report weighted samples
you get demographic information age
income state
all sorts of other things and then you
get responses to questions
yes no and the whole point here is to
estimate
whether or not in this case who in the
united states supports healthcare reform
um the the statistical model here is not
something super complicated
uh it's just the logistic regression i'm
being a little sloppy here with the
notation so please forgive me um what's
important is that inside this
x for each patient i or sorry each each
person i
we know something about their age their
sex their income their state
and we have a bunch of covariates there
so that's all i'm good that's easy
we can do that using other software what
but there's more that we want to do with
this
uh the the thing that we actually want
to do
is is hierarchical logistic regression
and what i mean by that is that the data
itself
comes in hierarchies in inside
structures
and we often want to estimate what ml
people usually call hyperparameters
and um you know we can imagine that
there's a state effect
average and the state effect standard
deviation
the first thing we should ask is does
that seem reasonable
um as a modeling assumption there are 50
states
there's got to be some sense of average
and variation right like
seems reasonable so let's go and
estimate it
the first thing you've got to know about
that is that maximum likelihood
actually doesn't work you end up with a
mathematically degenerate solution
the optimum if you try to do uh
this particular model is when the
variance is
exactly zero not close to zero exactly
zero
um and mathematically adding
regularization doesn't change the
optimum
you can try it out you can work out the
math you can do it in simulation
you'll just find out that the
when this model when you do maximum
likelihood
turns out that when all the states are
exactly the same
you end up with the best solution which
is against the
modeling principle that we had
so how do we do this it turns out the
bayesian inference works
and we can estimate the standard
standard deviation
from the data it ends up being close to
zero
like the maximum but not exactly and the
distribution of these estimates actually
capture our uncertainty
but wait there's more this isn't the
only thing we want to do
we want to add much more to our
statistical model we know that age is
continuous it's not a
you know bend like in this graph here
it's been from
1825 or 18 to 29
states are in regions so you know the
western states
are in the west region so on and so
forth so we we kind of have an idea that
certain there's a spatial
relationship we have to deal with
missing data
sensor data truncated data bad data
just all sorts of problems we know that
income is correlated with age
there are very few people that are very
young that make a ton of money that's
just how it works um and
we can go on and on so we actually need
more flexibility
so this is the motivating problem
when i was when stan first came about we
were trying to do these
political polling models and we wanted
to
do hierarchical models and continue to
increase the complexity of our models
so next i'm going to describe what stan
is um
stan's actually a combination of three
things these three
things together makeup stand it's the
language
algorithms and interfaces so the first
thing is it's a language for statistical
models
so the goal here is to specify a
statistical model
we start with the data x um this could
be multivariate it could be a time
series it could be anything but we're
just going to call it x
and we want to estimate some set of
parameters these parameters tell us
something about the world and how we
link these two together
is a model p
we treat that as a probability
distribution function so that's why we
call it p
but it's a function that links
parameters to data
if you just intuitively think about it
good values of parameters ends up with a
higher p
bad values of parameters ends up with a
lower p
um just for some technical details
stand self is its own language it has
its own grammar syntax
it's statically typed and imperative
and users define programs so they're
they're defining
data they're defining parameters and
they're defining this
model which is the log joint probability
distribution function
and the flexibility of this language
is that you can write any differentiable
joint probability
distribution function over the data and
parameters and that's
the whole point
so as a quick example this is logistic
regression
um and as i mentioned you can kind of
see that there's
data here there's parameters in the
second block sorry about that
there's data which is n
is the number of data points you have an
x
and you have y you have parameters
alpha and beta these are the two things
that we want to estimate
and this model statement is a
statistical
model saying that each observation y
which is either
one or zero uh is related by this
logistic function
logic of alpha plus beta times x
so this is how you would code logistic
regression stand
and so what we get is that the users are
defining the statistical model
it can be as complicated as they want it
can be very simple
but that's what the purpose of the
language is
next we have the inference algorithms so
the definition of the model doesn't tell
you what inference algorithm to use
in stan there are actually three
different classes of inference
algorithms
there's bayesian inference there's
approximate bayesian inference and
optimization
and just to get into some detail in
bayesian inference
the goal is to estimate the distribution
of your unknown parameters given the
data you see
so that's um that means that we're going
to approximate that
with theta parentheses one
is actually one set of thetas so if
theta is a thousand dimensional
we have one thousand dimensional draw
then we have a second one and we keep
doing that again and again
and this represents the uncertainty we
have around this
this data parameter the second type of
inference that
people use is approximately bayesian
inference
in our case this is advi automatic
differentiation
variational inference it's an automatic
scheme for doing
variational inference and that instead
of solving the actual problem that we
give
so we want to we want to estimate uh
we want to estimate this instead of that
we're going to find a function that
looks close enough to this
and that's what we're doing you can read
the map
somewhere else and then the third thing
that stan can also do is actually try to
find the optimum
so we want to find the best value of
theta for
for this function here and return it
and if you recall doing this over
hierarchical models ends up with
degenerate solutions so this is why
you know as soon as we start building
models we tend to use
bayesian inference because oftentimes it
ends up being hierarchical
by our modeling assumptions
the third thing that ties stand all
together are interfaces
and by interfaces we're talking about
things that can run stance so stan is
its own language
and these algorithms exist and you know
most of it's written in c
plus plus but we have to run it somehow
so in python there's pi standing command
stand
if you're in r julia command line
matlab of there's a bunch of different
interfaces that you can use so if you
have colleagues elsewhere
working with other tools that's not a
problem you know
in a sense the stand language you can
hand that program
over to someone else in a different
language and they can use it
there's also a c plus plus api if you
want to use that
there's an automatic differentiation
library in c
plus plus and then there are downstream
tools from stan
including rstan arm brms
profit you may have heard of it's by
facebook and it does time series
um pretty nicely
all right so now that i've described a
little about
what stan is and why it started i'll
talk to you about
when it's useful so there's a sweet spot
and it starts with off the shelf
packages don't include
encode your model so this is when your
favorite glm package
your favorite uh you know
logistic regression package i guess
that's a geon but whenever
you do that a time series package like
profit
when that stops being able to encode the
statistical model you want that's when
you start
you also want knowledge of your data
generating process
by that i mean you know something about
how your data was generated and you're
going to translate that into statistical
model assumptions
if you don't have that it's really tough
to use
the next thing you really want is you
tend to have
model that is complicated and often
hierarchical
because you want to use information
about the group to inform
what you know about individuals and
custom
custom in the sense that you know even
if you work with time
series data the package you use might
not have
truncation and censoring might only have
one of those
might not have particular nuances that
you have in your data
and it turns out like it's really good
when data is relatively small
relatively meaning relative to the
complicated the complexity
of your model so if you want to do
[Music]
so for example if you have a million
data points and two parameters that's
really easy
but if you have a thousand parameters
and a hundred data points
that's really hard to do and that's sort
of when you start using
more modeling assumptions and
statistical modeling
and that's when you can use stan the
last thing that stands really good for
is when you want interpretability
since this is a statistical modeling
language and it's a program
and you're specifying it with the
program you can actually
go and tell someone what that is
with that said there are difficulties
with using stan and i i should be honest
and tell you these things
um the first thing is modeling
not all models match data so
you can try to fit a logistic regression
to non-logistic data
and it's going to fail to produce good
output understanding
that leads to computation and new
diagnostics
there are new diagnostics and stand that
even the mcmc community haven't caught
up with
turns out the algorithms that we've
developed in stan
far surpassed the last generation of
algorithms
and that leads to new information that
we can use
to tell us when problems there are
problems
you also need some skills to use stan
really well
you need to be able to program and stand
which is yet another language so if
you're already comfortable in python
you know why would you pick up another
language um there's some
learning curve there and also once you
get used to the
basic syntaxes stand there's actually a
little bit of a leaky abstraction
you need to know a little bit about mcmc
a little bit about
a little bit about autodiff at this
point automatic differentiation
hopefully that changes over time but
right now in the state of computation
that is stan
you have to know these things to get
really good results
you may not have to but oftentimes you
won't
the last real big difficulty is that
they're no built-in models
this is both a blessing and a curse so
there
are no vetted can models with robust
built-in regularizations
and optimization and approximations so
if you know there is no time series
model with an ar1
that works on no matter what data you
give it um
that just doesn't exist you have to
write that
okay so the last part of the talk
is about why you stand and quick
disclaimer
this is going to be way oversimplified
uh there's a longer video if you want
i can send the link around um that was
done by jackie burrows
the head of data generable and a lot of
this work is her work
but the the video will will show the use
case and i'll describe some of it
all right so as i mentioned before
generable our company uses stand
what do we use it for the data that we
have
are clinical trials and oncology so
patients have tumor scans over time so
they come in they get
imaging and people measure the images
and measure tumor sizes so that's what
you're seeing on the right side
patients have events um some of them
observed some were censored some of them
are truncated
but over time you could see that the
number of people that are surviving
up to you know here it's 80 months and
this is simulated data here
and the goal that we have is to predict
survival
from early tumor data and what does that
mean
so early tumor data is if you look at
the left it's the black dots
ignore the ignore the um the predictions
there for a
second so it's the black dots and
you know if you follow them all the way
through you'd see all the way to the
to this to the non-filled dots
and here we're cutting off the sample at
you know just under 10 months
on the left patient and the the right
patient is cut off at 14 months
and what you see for the survivalist
observations the event observations is
you only get up to time 14 months here
so this isn't a lot of data from this
can we predict how well people are going
to respond to the treatment
um i'll get into the model that we use
it's a three-part model the first is a
tumor size
so we have a
this is sort of like a semi-mechanistic
model of tumor size
so we're going to say is that tumor size
at time
t um we have an estimate for the
baseline tumor size
and it's going to be the sum of two
exponentials f is a proportion
so if f is high then
most of the cells will shrink that's the
minus ks here
as time goes on and if f is low
we'll get more into this term which is
a regrowth term so most of the cells
will continue to multiply and get bigger
so that's the tumor size model the
second part of the model
is that we created these two
um i guess the best way to describe them
are
are metrics based on the parameters of
the
tumor model and they are
tumor shrinkage and turmeric growth and
they've been scaled down so that they're
there's some they're on the similar
scale here
and what you can see is that they are
sort of correlated here
and the way we use that is we associate
this part this is the association part
and we associate that with the survival
model if you're familiar with survival
model
this is the hazard on the left so at
time t
there's an instantaneous amount of risk
that a patient has
of seeing an event and this is a
proportional hazards model so there's a
baseline hazard here
and then you're multiplied by each
patient's
individual other factors of risk and in
here
these are smoking status age line of
therapy
gender so that gets into here but on top
of that
we have information about tumor
shrinkage and tumor regrowth
so the the modeling assumption here is
if your tumor shrinks you know maybe
maybe you should
have a better chance of surviving or
longer survival
less risk
right so
how does this work you know this i
originally showed you
the observations from phase two what
would look like a phase two study
what we do is we estimate what happened
to the phase 3 study so first thing we
do is we project
out from 30 patients to 300 this is what
would happen in a phase
3 study that's why these lines are not
exactly the same as the cam curves
earlier their earlier plot
and from that little data we're
estimating
these curves for both the control and
the treatment so it works
fairly well the more data we get the
closer we are
so that's our actual use case and you
know there's much more to it
um and so i'll conclude with
you know why stand why do we use stan um
we have knowledge about the data
generating process
we've encoded that using a tumor
dynamics model with association
in the survival model
the model is complicated and data is
precious
here it's clinical trials so
there just aren't an infinite number of
patients that we can recruit for these
trials
that requires a lot of follow-up and
you know when i say the model is
complicated not only
is this three-part model you know
difficult to code but we also have to
deal with real
things like truncated events meaning we
don't see the event yet
someone left the study centered data
there are times when uh the
measurements don't come out in labs
because it's under some sort of limit
that can be detected we know that
there's some
something there but we just don't know
um we have to use a little bit of
hierarchical structure here
um because there's only a few patients
where we're our modeling assumptions are
that certain patients are actually very
similar to each other and others are
we end up with an interpretable model
and
by interpretable here it's longer
overall survival is seen with shrinkage
and tumor
that's what we're expecting and that's
what we see that's great
um and yeah there
there is no off the shelf package for
this model um
yep that doesn't exist so we had to do
this on our own
the last thing i do want to mention is
that we're continually
learning more about the generating data
generating process so this is just
one iteration in uh many
of this model um you know next week next
month next year
we'll have another version and another
version and so having a tool like stan
is really good for us because we can
write our models in this and continue to
expand them
and that's my last slide thank you
that's how to reach me
and i'm happy to take questions
hi thanks um daniel for this uh
interesting uh uh a peek under the hood
uh for
stan um so let's go to the questions
so i see one question from juan on
discord
asking how did you come up with the
tumor size
model equation is it a standard in the
oncology field
to use these exponential models or is it
something else
that's a great question this one is um
one of the
more common ones in the field maybe not
more common there there are a few that
are common
um there there are different class of
models um
some of them are what they call
empirical
meaning that they just have a functional
form it's mathematic they look at the
data
and they find a functional form for it
um and then there are others that are
mechanistic or semi-mechanistic
which describe how they believe the
tumors to work and this one's kind of
the mix in between
and the sum of exponentials actually
makes it so that it captures a lot of
the dynamics so a lot
of patience tumor scans over time
actually fit this dynamic
not perfectly but you know it's it's
the body is really really complicated
and
there there is a modeling trade-off we
could do something
much much more complicated and
unfortunately we don't have enough data
to to back that up so
we have to simplify the model to get
estimates that make sense
okay great thanks uh for answer i have
another one
from one of our committee members um
so do you have examples when to start
modeling in stone
instead of just using perhaps linear
mixed effects models packages
uh when to start uh i think
it'll come down to
a lot of people start with stan when
they start
um running into
hidden assumptions uh not understanding
what's happening with
like if you specify a model and the
solutions that you come back
are not what you expect you're now
touching like either a bug a weird
property in the model
a weird property in the inference
algorithm and
like a lot of a lot of people start
there um
coming in from that side uh
other practitioners just start using
stand because they come from places
where
they're used to writing statistical
models on their own
so i'd say you know it's always good to
start with toy examples
but you're really going to stick with it
when you when you get to a point where
you have to use it
okay cool thanks and maybe uh last one
uh
also tying into our next presentation so
we have someone uh discussing uh
by mc3 could you maybe sort of give your
take on the differences and why should
we use stan
instead of uh phi mc3
yeah um pi mc3 is a great package um
you know i know a lot of people that
work on it it's
the goals are slightly different stan
was made to be
um stan historically we
we borrowed a lot of the language syntax
based on bugs and
jags so there's that's the community
that we started with
and so stan is its own language a lot of
people that are pythonic
find it pretty offensive you have to
learn another language
so if you're pythonic i get it stick
with
python stigma please e3 there are speed
differences and there are
um breath differences like
right now stan there you can do a little
more withstand
this won't be forever right both
languages are changing and improving so
hopefully everything gets to the same
spot and you have an equal choice
for right now for us it's it's speed and
flexibility
all right okay thanks uh daniel thanks a
lot for for making the time all the way
from uh
from the u.s um and uh
giving this great presentation answering
a question so um
daniel if you have some time later to
look at the
discord channel to see if there's any
other questions coming up um
and for now uh yeah thanks a lot for for
your time
yeah i'll be on there for a few minutes
thanks all right okay thanks
you